Parents can learn a lot from that.
But to me, "adapt all the time" means something deeper, too.
We have to break parents out of this straitjacket
that the only ideas we can try at home
are ones that come from shrinks or self-help gurus
or other family experts.
The truth is, their ideas are stale,
whereas in all these other worlds there are these new ideas
to make groups and teams work effectively.
Let's just take a few examples.
Let's take the biggest issue of all: family dinner.
Everybody knows that having family dinner
with your children is good for the kids.
But for so many of us, it doesn't work in our lives.
I met a celebrity chef in New Orleans who said,
"No problem, I'll just time-shift family dinner.
I'm not home, can't make family dinner?
We'll have family breakfast. We'll meet for a bedtime snack.
We'll make Sunday meals more important."
And the truth is, recent research backs him up.
It turns out there's only 10 minutes of productive time
in any family meal.
The rest of it's taken up with "take your elbows off the table" and "pass the ketchup."
You can take that 10 minutes and move it
to any part of the day and have the same benefit.
So time-shift family dinner. That's adaptability.
An environmental psychologist told me,
"If you're sitting in a hard chair on a rigid surface,
you'll be more rigid.
If you're sitting on a cushioned chair, you'll be more open."
She told me, "When you're discipling your children,
sit in an upright chair with a cushioned surface.
The conversation will go better."
My wife and I actually moved where we sit for difficult conversations
because I was sitting above in the power position.
So move where you sit. That's adaptability.
The point is there are all these new ideas out there.
We've got to hook them up with parents.
So plank number one: Adapt all the time.
Be flexible, be open-minded, let the best ideas win.
Plank number two: Empower your children.
Our instinct as parents is to order our kids around.
It's easier, and frankly, we're usually right.
There's a reason that few systems have been more
waterfall over time than the family.
But the single biggest lesson we learned
is to reverse the waterfall as much as possible.
Enlist the children in their own upbringing.
Just yesterday, we were having our family meeting,
and we had voted to work on overreacting.
So we said, "Okay, give us a reward and give us a punishment. Okay?"
So one of my daughters threw out, you get five minutes of overreacting time all week.
So we kind of liked that.
But then her sister started working the system.
She said, "Do I get one five-minute overreaction
or can I get 10 30-second overreactions?"
I loved that. Spend the time however you want.
Now give us a punishment. Okay.
If we get 15 minutes of overreaction time, that's the limit.
Every minute above that, we have to do one pushup.
So you see, this is working. Now look, this system isn't lax.
There's plenty of parental authority going on.
But we're giving them practice becoming independent,
which of course is our ultimate goal.
Just as I was leaving to come here tonight,
one of my daughters started screaming.
The other one said, "Overreaction! Overreaction!"
and started counting, and within 10 seconds it had ended.
To me that is a certified agile miracle.
(Laughter) (Applause)
And by the way, research backs this up too.
Children who plan their own goals, set weekly schedules,
evaluate their own work build up their frontal cortex
and take more control over their lives.
The point is, we have to let our children succeed on their own terms,
and yes, on occasion, fail on their own terms.
I was talking to Warren Buffett's banker,
and he was chiding me for not letting my children
make mistakes with their allowance.
And I said, "But what if they drive into a ditch?"
He said, "It's much better to drive into a ditch
with a $6 allowance than a $60,000-a-year salary
or a $6 million inheritance."
So the bottom line is, empower your children.
Plank number three: Tell your story.
Adaptability is fine, but we also need bedrock.
Jim Collins, the author of "Good To Great,"
told me that successful human organizations of any kind
have two things in common:
they preserve the core, they stimulate progress.
So agile is great for stimulating progress,
but I kept hearing time and again, you need to preserve the core.
So how do you do that?
Collins coached us on doing something
that businesses do, which is define your mission
and identify your core values.
So he led us through the process of creating a family mission statement.
We did the family equivalent of a corporate retreat.
We had a pajama party.
I made popcorn. Actually, I burned one, so I made two.
My wife bought a flip chart.
And we had this great conversation, like, what's important to us?
What values do we most uphold?
And we ended up with 10 statements.
We are travelers, not tourists.
We don't like dilemmas. We like solutions.
Again, research shows that parents should spend less time
worrying about what they do wrong
and more time focusing on what they do right,
worry less about the bad times and build up the good times.
This family mission statement is a great way to identify
what it is that you do right.
A few weeks later, we got a call from the school.
One of our daughters had gotten into a spat.
And suddenly we were worried, like, do we have a mean girl on our hands?
And we didn't really know what to do,
so we called her into my office.
The family mission statement was on the wall,
and my wife said, "So, anything up there seem to apply?"
And she kind of looked down the list, and she said,
"Bring people together?"
Suddenly we had a way into the conversation.
Another great way to tell your story
is to tell your children where they came from.
Researchers at Emory gave children a simple
"what do you know" test.
Do you know where your grandparents were born?
Do you know where your parents went to high school?
Do you know anybody in your family
who had a difficult situation, an illness, and they overcame it?
The children who scored highest on this "do you know" scale
had the highest self-esteem and a greater sense they could control their lives.
The "do you know" test was the single biggest predictor
of emotional health and happiness.
As the author of the study told me,
children who have a sense of -- they're part of a larger narrative
have greater self-confidence.
So my final plank is, tell your story.
Spend time retelling the story of your family's positive moments
and how you overcame the negative ones.
If you give children this happy narrative,
you give them the tools to make themselves happier.
I was a teenager when I first read "Anna Karenina"
and its famous opening sentence,
"All happy families are alike.
Each unhappy family is unhappy in its own way."
When I first read that, I thought, "That sentence is inane.
Of course all happy families aren't alike."
But as I began working on this project,
I began changing my mind.
Recent scholarship has allowed us, for the first time,
to identify the building blocks
that successful families have.
I've mentioned just three here today:
Adapt all the time, empower the children, tell your story.
Is it possible, all these years later, to say Tolstoy was right?
The answer, I believe, is yes.
When Leo Tolstoy was five years old,
his brother Nikolay came to him
and said he had engraved the secret to universal happiness
on a little green stick, which he had hidden
in a ravine on the family's estate in Russia.
If the stick were ever found, all humankind would be happy.
Tolstoy became consumed with that stick, but he never found it.
In fact, he asked to be buried in that ravine where he thought it was hidden.
He still lies there today, covered in a layer of green grass.
That story perfectly captures for me
the final lesson that I learned:
Happiness is not something we find,
it's something we make.
Almost anybody who's looked at well-run organizations
has come to pretty much the same conclusion.
Greatness is not a matter of circumstance.
It's a matter of choice.
You don't need some grand plan. You don't need a waterfall.
You just need to take small steps,
accumulate small wins,
keep reaching for that green stick.
In the end, this may be the greatest lesson of all.
What's the secret to a happy family? Try.
(Applause)